este es el día número 141 desde que
comenzó la invasión rusia ucrania y es
una jornada con nuevos ataques a
diferentes ciudades tal vez el más
significativo ha sucedido en la ciudad
de vinicio una gran ciudad en el centro
del país que ha pasado jugar un papel
bastante significativo desde el comienzo
de la guerra porque ha acogido a miles y
a miles de desplazados internos tres
misiles cayeron esta mañana en el centro
de la ciudad las autoridades
especialmente el ministro de defensa
habla que desde que comenzó la guerra
han caído al menos tres mil misiles en
todo el país uno de ellos también cayó
esta mañana en esta ciudad de mykolaiv
en el mar negro que sacan atacada
constantemente por las tropas rusas
varias edificaciones fueron alcanzadas
por estos misiles entre ellos un colegio
y también siguen los ataques en el este
del país en la región del donbass donde
las ciudades del siglo bians y bach mut
cada vez son centros de la guerra más
cada vez son más atacados a pesar de ese
parón operativo del que habían hablado
los rusos